what's a rational equation well rational
means ratio right so like a fraction
okay I have two quantities you can see
this is equation it's an equation made
up of a fractions right so what we're
going to do to solve these rational
equations is we're going to clear the
denominators so the way we do that is
let's go to this example here as we find
the common denominator for all the
fractions we multiply through by that
common denominator and what that does is
it clears the denominators eliminating
the fractions making it a little bit
easier for us to solve so let's go ahead
and take a look at this one what's the
common denominator for all three of
these fractions can you tell if you're
going to get a common denominator for
all these like say you were going to add
them together for example what would you
want that common denominator to be well
we would want it to be 4x so what we're
going to do is we're going to multiply
the entire equation by 4x you can think
of that as 4x over 1 and what we're
gonna do is we're gonna take that we're
gonna distribute it to each of these
fractions we're doing it to the left on
the right side so it keeps that equation
balanced right but when we do this when
we distribute it to the first fraction
see how those X's are going to cancel
because ones in the numerator ones in
the denominator leaving us with just 4
times 3 which is 12 we've eliminated
that denominator right now when we
distribute it to the next one the fours
are gonna cancel numerator denominator
we gonna be left with x times 2 so minus
2x because that minus sign there and
then here when we multiply the four X's
are gonna cancel we're just gonna be
left with 8 so you can see we
effectively cleared the denominators we
can solve this fresh this equation very
easily now we just have to subtract 12
from both sides so that gives us
negative 2x equals negative 4 divided by
negative 2 and x equals 2 now the last
thing I want to mention is when you're
doing these rational equations is you
want to make sure that the answer
doesn't make any of the denominators 0
because you can't divide by 0 right
because that's undefined so if you go to
put the 2 back in that's okay that's
okay you just don't want X to be 0 in
this case because that would make the
denominator 0 making the fresh